على مكتب محافظ القدس لنا شابين فلسطينيين
شقيقين استشهد في حادث دهس متعمد ارتكبهم
مستوطن قرب حاجزي زعتره العسكري جنوب
نابلس في الضفه الغربيه المحتله اضاف
المصدره ان الشابين محمد ومهند مطير من
مخيم قلنديا للاجئين كنا يقفان على جانب
احد الطرق لاصلاح اثارات سيارتهما قرب
الحاجز عندما صدمهما مستوطن السعودي
بسيارته عمدا
لمصرع احدهما فورا ونقل الثاني لمستشفى
الاسرائيليه حيث توفى لاحقا لقد كانت
فصائل وفصائل وقوه وطنيه فلسطينيه جريمه
الدهس ودعت الى تصعيد المقاومه ضد
الاحتلال وقالت حركه حماس ان عمليه الدهس
البشعه والمتعمده متوقعه مع صعود اليمين
المتطرف الذي يصعده من انتهاكاته
بحق ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
وقد اكد احمد يوسف مطير شقيقه الشهيدين
محمد ومهند الذي كان معهم لحظه الحادثه ان
المستوطنه تعمد دهسهم السياره
بعيده خبر في السياره
الله بس الله من فوق سلامنا
اخذ اللي اخذ منهن والحمد لله رب العالمين
[موسيقى]
في حضور ذلك خرجت من وسطي المخيم قلنديا
شمال القدس المحتله مسيره غاضبه جابت ازقه
المخيم اثر استشهاد الشابين واعلن في
القوه الوطنيه في المخيم
[موسيقى]